on s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur nous refusons de voir la
France devenir chaque jour un peu plus
l'eldorado de la clandestinité l'accueil
du bateau au chêne Viking et ses 234
migrants finalement donné lieu au fiasco
judiciaire et sécuritaire inévitable et
annoncé à la fois sur votre engagement
monsieur le ministre d'éloignement
immédiat des déboutés du droit d'asile
la majorité s'étant évanouie dans la
nature faute d’être présenté un juge
dans les délais et sur le contrôle des
mineurs isolés dont 60% ontugué le
président Emmanuel Macron qui il est
vrai n'est pas un revirement prêt
déclaré pourtant en 2018 à propos de
l'Aquarius que si la France devenait le
port d'accueil des bateaux qui partent
d'Afrique ce serait insoutenable et que
les bons sentiments faciles feraient
juste basculer le pays vers les extrêmes
il faut un message limpide et plus ferme
vous aviez entamé à votre prise de
fonction une tournée de plusieurs pays
pour négocier des laisser passer
consulaires et augmenter l'exécution des
expulsions dont 9 sur 10 reste
aujourd'hui toujours l'être morte mais
l'octroi des visas réguliers et l'aide
au développement doivent être dans les
conditionner à la délivrance
systématique délaissez passer
consulaires pour éloigner les
clandestins il faut ensuite affirmer
sans aucune ambiguïté que les ONG et
leur bateau sont les complices
désorganisations criminelles et
mafieuses de passeurs qui provoque de la
misère et des drames humains en mer la
France doit soutenir la demande de
résolution des quatre pays
méditerranéens qui exigent que les pays
qui fournissent leur pavillon au bateau
privé des ONG en accueille alors les
migrants et assurent leur prise en
charge mais question sont donc directes
monsieur le ministre écoutez vous enfin
les propositions de la droite
républicaine pour bâtir une politique
migratoire ferme et réaliste assurant la
sécurité de nos concitoyens
l'éloignement de ceux qui violent nos
lois et permettent l'intégration des
personnes qui méritent réellement d'être
accueillies ou alors attendez-vous comme
Gérard Collomb de quitter le
gouvernement pour dénoncer l'hypocrisie
laxiste du pouvoir et le dévoiement des
procédures migratoires qui affaiblissent
notre République je vous